on our planet we have two polar regions
the arctic whose name comes from the
greek arcticos of the north and the
antarctic from antarcticos opposite of
the north but there is an easier way to
remember them if you just remember what
surrounds them
the arctic situated in the northern
hemisphere of our planet is an ocean
entirely surrounded by land
on the other side of the world the
antarctic is a continent entirely
surrounded by ocean
so the arctic has polar bears but no
penguins and the antarctic has penguins
but no polar bears
let's talk about the arctic first the
arctic region consists of a vast
ice-covered ocean surrounded by treeless
permafrost
the area can be defined as the region
between the arctic circle and the north
pole
if you were to stand at the north pole
everywhere you looked in all directions
would be south
but standing at the north pole is
difficult to do for very long because
it's in the middle of an ocean covered
by constantly shifting frozen sea ice
if you were to fall into the water at
the north pole you'd fall into water
that's 13
980 feet deep
above the water average winter
temperatures can be as low as negative
40 degrees celsius
and the coldest recorded temperature is
approximately negative 68 degrees
celsius
despite these incredibly harsh
conditions humans have populated areas
in the arctic for thousands of years
life in the arctic includes organisms
living in the ice zooplankton and
phytoplankton fish and marine mammals
birds land animals plants and human
societies
okay what about antarctica
antarctica is earth's southernmost
continent and it contains the geographic
south pole
it's the fifth largest continent on the
planet at nearly twice the size of
australia
almost 98 of antarctica is covered by
ice at least one mile in thickness
conditions in antarctica are some of the
most extreme in the entire world
on average it's the coldest windiest
driest continent and has the highest
average elevation of all the continents
you might think that it snows all the
time at the poles but antarctica is so
dry it's considered a desert with annual
precipitation of only 200 millimeters
along the coast and far less inland the
temperature in antarctica has reached
negative 89 degrees celsius
because it's so harsh and hard to get to
there are no permanent human residents
on antarctica but anywhere from a
thousand to five thousand people reside
throughout the year at the research
station scattered across the continent
even the most extreme animals fight for
survival and only cold adapted organisms
survive there including many types of
algae animals bacteria
fungi plants and protista
but why is antarctica colder than its
northern cousin well first much of the
continent is more than three kilometers
above sea level and temperature
decreases with elevation that's why
mountaintops have snow on them
second remember that the arctic is
really a frozen ocean
the water in the ocean beneath it is
warmer than the frozen ground in the
antarctic and that warmth is transferred
through the ice pack
this prevents temperatures in the arctic
regions from reaching the extremes
typical of the land surface of
antarctica
third the seasons are conspiring against
the antarctic
during the aphelion in july when the
earth is the farthest away from the sun
it also happens to be winter in the
antarctic which creates a double whammy
of cold for the southern pole
but despite being inhospitable the north
and south pole are a big reason why our
planet is the way it is
both of our polar regions are very
important climate controllers they help
moderate the temperature in our
temperate zones and give us stable
weather
as sea ice in the arctic declines due to
climate change and global warming
weather around the globe becomes
increasingly more unstable
you